we begin in Sudan which has seen some of
its heaviest fighting since the conflict
began between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces just
hours after a one-day humanitarian
ceasefire ended explosions heavy gunfire
and ground battles were reported in
Khartoum and several other parts of the
country hibber Morgan reports from
onderman
more artillery fire and explosions into
Sudan's capital Khartoum just as a
24-hour ceasefire between the Army and
paramilitary Rapid support forces came
to an end on Sunday morning the Army
quickly moved in to gain full control of
a bridge that connects the city of
onderman to the northern part of the
capital
[Music]
came here in the morning and they ran I
shot them with my Kalashnikov why are
they running because we're here
for its part the rsf says it was able to
repel attacks by the Army in parts of
hartum and Destroy its Vehicles
a message to our commander we're waiting
for your orders and we will raid the
general command of the army we don't
want any delays
at times residential areas in different
parts of the capital turned into
Battlegrounds with civilians caught in
the middle Army airstrikes were also
reported around Khartoum
artillery fire and shelling killed
several civilians in the southern part
of the capital on Sunday hundreds more
have died since the start of the
fighting in mid-april and thousands
injured but Khartoum is not the only
region where violence has led to
civilian casualties
the capital of Sudan's West Darfur State
a region already devastated by two
decades of War saw the return of ethnic
Arab militias backed by the rapid
support forces targeting the ethnic
Masala tribe doctors in the state
compared the violence there to the 1994
Rwandan Genocide calling it catastrophic
they say at least a thousand civilians
have been killed since the start of the
fighting eight weeks ago and hundreds
endured hospitals have ceased
functioning while thousands have fled to
neighboring Chad for safety but
thousands more remain behind trapped in
a decades-long ethnic conflict made
worse by the recent fighting Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera on durman
well as ever mentioned there are
thousands of people are fleeing the
violence in Western Darfur they're
escaping into neighboring Chad Zane Bas
Ravi has more from Audrey in eastern
Chad
this is a place where eight
organizations are poised to try to deal
with this enormous humanitarian
catastrophe that
hour by hour day by day just keeps
getting worse we've been speaking to
refugees that have been pouring in from
westar4 we can surmise from the uptick
of people that have been coming in that
there has been a lull in the fighting
that is allowed for people to try to get
out but as soon as they arrive here they
tell us that ongoing fighting skirmishes
gun battles Street to Street battles
those are still continuing in elginina
City everyone we've been speaking to
says the same thing that they are being
targeted by Arab militias that those of
the African masalit tribe often have to
lie about who they are to try to get
through checkpoints where they have to
pay for their freedom where they are
robbed of their cell phones and almost
entirely all of their property where
they are experiencing severe beatings
men women children no one is being
spared the indignities of those
checkpoints and despite that they feel
lucky to get out because they say not
everybody does we've spoken to multiple
people who have had relatives killed who
have been split up from their families
who don't know where the rest of their
groups are because during their Journey
they faced gunfire they faced attacks by
militias and they were split up running
into forests getting out any way that
they could
originally there's a gathering in
Djibouti to push for a ceasefire in
Sudan Bennett Smith has the latest from
Djibouti
the leaders of seven East African
nations will meet here in Djibouti on
Monday and the top of their agenda is
going to be Sudan and the conflict and
the fighting there but ahead of that the
leaders of Djibouti and Kenya have
already met on our bilateral meeting
William Ruto the Kenyan president he
said that the situation in Sudan is bad
and getting worse and more complicated
and the leaders of igad this East
African Union must put an end to this
war and the president of Djibouti Ismail
guela he said we demand an end to the
suffering of the Sudanese and we will
work with regional leaders to put an end
to that suffering but the challenge for
these leaders is what leverage can they
bring to bear on the two warring
factions in Sudan many ceasefires have
not held there was one for 24 hours that
just about held negotiated by the U.S
and Saudi Arabia can the leaders of
these East African countries do
something similar they need to because
there's already 1.9 million people
internally displaced by the fight
against Sudan many coming across the
poorest borders into those neighboring
countries it's a crisis for these
countries too and they need to bring a
solution to the fighting in Sudan
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Djibouti